from retro-style brass lamps to steel
coffee tables a cabinet with a metal
base or a chair made of recycled
aluminium metal furniture is in this
year Italian furniture maker of pinyon
shotty has brought it a whole collection
constructed from materials including
cast iron bronze copper gold and sheet
metal follow your roots is the
brainchild of lap o chatting he drew
inspiration for the series from palaces
and rooms I think the customers now is
open to to buy furniture made by metal
because is more durability there is is
more stronger of course and with metal
we can do it a lot of special finishes
that is impossible to do it with other
material opinion Chelsea founded in 1950
has been producing metal furniture for
decades this 2004 steelbook case won the
company the compasso de Oro one of the
world's most coveted design accolades
the ill tavolo table from the current
collection boasts a finish in silver
gold or copper leaf the designer also
came up with an exclusive extra touch
after the finish of copper leaf we put a
special upper surface that is called
nano ceramic that didn't make it
stronger and feeling better you need
only look at international furniture
trade fairs like last April Salone del
Mobile a in Milan to see that a new
metal age has begun even plastic
furniture maker cartels new collection
features metallic colors and British
designer Tom Dixon is a major motor
behind the copper and bronze revival
German design expert Matteo Cree says
the move toward metal furniture reflects
a wider social phenomenon
Capulet hums on his end of the day I
think people want things that are
authentic it's a reaction to the digital
age we're in where everything is
immaterial virtual light and intangible
metal is tangible heavy and physical
that's maybe a reason why people are
interested in it as a staff every day it
was here until the late 19th century
metal furniture was primarily used in
hospitals in the 1920s metal moved into
people's living rooms it was the great
innovation in furniture design the minds
behind the Bauhaus movement experimented
with steel tubes and championed the
cantilever chair it was the initial step
in a revolution that lasted until the
60s the other side of the story are the
explorations of the properties of metals
questions of structural engineering and
manufacturing procedures that's really
interesting because design gets coupled
with technological innovations which
lead to genuine aesthetic innovation one
man who experiments with manufacturing
techniques is Konstantin Grichuk in 2003
the German design chair one from dye
cast aluminium in 2008 Poland's Oscar
CEATEC created a commotion with plop a
still made by inflating steel plates
with air that makes every single one
unique a real exception in mass-produced
design
metal furniture enthusiasts love the
special properties of the material metal
furniture camera can have a very strong
identity anyway it's metal anyway so
special because it's not cold I like
very much metal furniture because I can
mix it very well with all furniture made
by wood so the in credit is big into
metal this year but if it isn't your
thing don't get bent out of shape it
can't be long before wood is back in
fashion